Traductor: Paulina Segovia
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
El órgano más grande de tu cuerpo
no es tu hígado o tu cerebro.
Es tu piel, con una superficie de unos
1,86 metros cuadrados en los adultos.
Aunque muchas áreas de la piel
tienen características diferentes,
mucha de esta superficie
realiza funciones similares,
como transpirar, sentir calor y frío,
y crecer pelo.
Pero luego de un corte profundo
o una herida,
la nueva piel se verá diferente
al área que la rodea,
y puede que no recupere totalmente
sus habilidades durante un tiempo,
o en absoluto.
Para comprender por qué sucede esto,
necesitamos mirar la estructura
de la piel humana.
La capa superior, llamada epidermis,
consiste sobretodo en células endurecidas,
llamadas queratinocitos,
que dan protección.
Dado que esta capa externa
se cambia y renueva constantemente,
es muy fácil repararla.
Pero a veces una herida penetra
en la dermis,
la cual contiene vasos sanguíneos,
varias glándulas y terminaciones nerviosas
que permiten
las muchas funciones de la piel.
Y cuando eso sucede,
desencadena los 4 procesos sobrepuestos
del proceso de regeneración.
La primera etapa, hemostasia,
es la respuesta de la piel
a dos amenazas inmediatas:
que estás perdiendo sangre
y que la barrera física de la epidermis
ha sido dañada.
A medida que los vasos sanguíneos
se contrajeron
para reducir al mínimo el sangrado,
en un proceso llamado vasoconstricción,
las dos amenazas se evitan al
formar un coágulo de sangre.
Una proteína especial
conocida como fibrina,
forma enlaces cruzados
en la superficie de la piel,
evitando que la sangre fluya hacia afuera
y que entren bacterias o patógenos.
Luego de alrededor de 3 horas,
la piel se empieza a poner roja,
indicando la nueva etapa,
la inflamación.
Cuando el sangrado está bajo control
y la barrera asegurada,
el cuerpo envía células especializadas
para luchar contra cualquier patógeno
que pudiera haber entrado.
Entre las más importantes de estas
están los glóbulos blancos,
llamados macrófagos, que devoran
a bacterias y tejido dañado
en un proceso llamado fagocitosis,
además de producir factores de crecimiento
para estimular la curación.
Y dado que estos diminutos soldados
necesitan viajar por la sangre
para llegar hasta el sitio dañado,
los vasos sanguíneos contraídos,
ahora se expanden en un
proceso llamado vasodilatación.
Dos o tres días después de la herida,
ocurre la etapa proliferativa,
en que las células fibroblastos
entran en la herida.
En el proceso de deposición de colágeno,
producen una proteína fibrosa
llamada colágeno en la zona herida,
formando tejido conectivo
para reemplazar la fibrina anterior.
Mientras que las células epidérmicas
se dividen para regenerar
la capa externa de la piel, la dermis
se contrae para cerrar la herida.
Finalmente, en la cuarta etapa
de remodelación,
la herida madura cuando el colágeno
depositado se reorganiza
y se convierte en tipos específicos.
Mediante este proceso,
que puede tomar hasta un año,
la resistencia a la tracción
de la piel nueva mejora,
y los vasos sanguíneos y otras conexiones
se fortalecen.
Con el tiempo, el nuevo tejido
puede alcanzar el 50 a 80%
de sus funciones originales,
dependiendo de la gravedad
de la herida inicial y de la función
en sí misma.
Pero como la piel no se recupera 100%,
la cicatrización sigue siendo
un problema clínico importante
para los médicos de todo el mundo.
Y a pesar de que los investigadores
han hecho avances significativos
en la comprensión del proceso de curación,
muchos misterios fundamentales
permanecen sin resolver.
Por ejemplo, ¿los fibroblastos llegan
por los vasos sanguíneos
o del tejido de la piel
adyacente a la herida?
¿Y por qué algunos otros mamíferos,
como los ciervos,
curan sus heridas mucho más eficiente
y completamente que los seres humanos?
Encontrando las respuestas a estas
y otras preguntas,
podremos ser capaces, algún día,
de sanarnos tan bien a nosotros mismos
que las cicatrices quedarán
solo en el recuerdo.